let's start with a big broad question
what is socialism
how do you like to Define it how do you
like to think about it well there's so
many socialists out there and we can't
seem to agree about anything so my
definition I'm sure is you know really
just my definition but I think at the
minimum socialism is about making sure
that the core necessities of life
food housing education and so on are
guaranteed to everyone just by virtue of
being born so that those people can
reach their potential and I think that's
a that's a minimum requirement of
socialism beyond that I think socialism
especially Democratic socialism the type
of socialism that I believe in is about
taking democracy from just the political
Democratic realm and extending it into
economic and social spheres as well so
if we think that democracy is a good
thing why do we allow our workplaces to
be run in autocratic ways so economic
political social in all those Realms the
the ideas the philosophical ideas apply
like what what are if you can put words
to it what are some
philosophical ideas about human beings
that are at the core of this I think at
the core it's the idea that we have
intrinsic value we are individuals that
have unequal talents of course we're
individuals that want different things
but this unique individualness can only
Truly Come to light in a society in
which there are certain Collective or
social guarantees so we could think just
like Stephen J Gould the scientists and
socialist used to say about how many
thousands of potential Einsteins or
Leonardo da Vinci's that died you know
in sweatshops and on plantations and
never got the chance to cultivate what
was unique and human about themselves
and also never got a chance to have
families and in part what was special
and important to them to Future
generations and to posterity my own
grandmother
I was born in Trinidad and Tobago she
was illiterate till her dying days she'd
been in East Orange New Jersey she never
had the chance to write down her
memories of her life in Trinidad as a
young woman and what it meant she of
course had lots of children she was able
to impart some stories to her children
and grandchildren but I often think
about what someone with her with an
intelligence could have done with with a
little bit more support
but if all human beings have intrinsic
value you don't have to be an Einstein
for the application some of the ideas
that you're talking about is there a
tension or a trade-off between
our human civilization our society
helping the Unlucky versus rewarding
the skillful and the hard-working I
think you could do both there's always a
balance between the two I think you
could reward people who make Innovations
and and and we would improve lives for
everyone through their Innovations by
giving them let's say even more
consumption even that level of
inequality while still making sure that
there's not people in in poverty and
suffering and while making sure that hey
we're gonna give these people who want
to work that extra 10 hours or 20 hours
or want to apply their their hard work
um some some extra benefits but that
these benefits would be not the extreme
disparities that you have today
so at the core of socialism and maybe
Democratic socialism is a maybe a
reallocation of wealth reallocation of
resources I think it's wealth and
resources yes but it's also power and I
guess one way to think about this is
some thinkers on the right like Hayek
they would say in their most generous
moments talking about socialists and
socialism they would say socialists want
to trade some of your freedom for
equality
and that's them trying to just
accurately describe what socialism is
trying to do the way that I would put it
is a little bit different socialists are
proposing a trade-off but it's really a
trade-off between freedom and freedom
and by that I mean let's say you set up
a successful business
and you set up a business right here in
Austin Texas some sort of firm it's
producing some widget or or whatever and
it's producing
a good that people really want and
demand but you have some competition
um you uh decide to hire 20 30 people to
help you you entered into a free
contract with these people
who under capitalism of course we're not
living in feudalism have the option to
join any other firm but they like you
and they like this firm and they like
your offer and you're paying them let's
say twenty dollars an hour for
um 40 hours of work per week now if the
government comes along and says
okay there's now a new minimum wage the
minimum wage is 22 dollars an hour and
also there's a maximum work week 35 hour
work week and if you work someone over
35 hours even if they agree you have to
pay them time and a half
now that of course is now an abridgement
of your freedom as an entrepreneur your
freedom to set certain terms of
employment to engage in a contract with
free people but now your workers and
other workers in the sector because if
you did it unilaterally you just get
undercut by your competition now these
people now have a few extra hours a week
they can do whatever they want with you
know they could watch more NFL with it
they could you know spend more time with
their friends or family or whatever else
and they're still getting paid the same
if not better because because the wages
also went up so it's really a question
often of trade-offs between who whose
freedom and autonomy are you going to
prioritize the freedom and autonomy of
the entrepreneur
um or the capitalist in this case or the
freedom of autonomy of ordinary workers
now you could create a society that
swings so far in the direction of
um prioritizing the freedom of one group
or one class or whatever else compared
to another that you end up in some sort
of tyranny now if the state said
you know you Lex you're you're a
capitalist so you don't get the right to
vote or we're going to take away your
private home or your ability to to do
um things that we think are intrinsic
human rights now this would be tyranny
this would be an abridgement of of your
your rights but shaping your ability in
the economic sphere to be in an economic
actor is I think within the realm and
scope of democratic politics
yeah so those are the extremes you're
referring to and uh
one perspective I like to take on
socialism versus capitalism is
under each system the extremes of each
systems and the moderate versions of
each system
how can people take advantage of it
so it seems like no matter what part of
human nature is whatever the rules
whatever the framework whatever the
system somebody's going to take
advantage of it and
that's the kind of pragmatic look at it
in practice what actually happens also
the incentives and the human behavior
what actually happens in practice under
these systems so if you have a higher
and higher minimum wage and people watch
more and more NFL how does that change
their actual Behavior as a productive
member of society and actually at the
individual level
as somebody
as somebody who could be an Einstein and
chooses not to because NFL is so awesome
to watch so like it's both how do people
malicious people that want to take
advantage maybe not malicious but
people that like me are lazy and want to
take advantage uh and people that
also I think like me like I I tend to
believe about myself that I have
potential
and if I let my laziness naturally take
over which it often does I won't
materialize the potential
so if you
um if you make life too easy for me I
feel like I will never get anything done
me personally of course there's a giant
set of circumstances of The Unlucky and
the overburdened and so on okay so how
can people take advantage of each system
socialism capitalism so for one thing
people are going to take advantage of
systems they're going to find loopholes
they're going to find ways around
they're going to find ways to to at
times Dominate and chorus others even in
systems meant to get rid of domination
and coercion that's why we need to
design our systems in our such a way
that that it eliminates as many of these
things as possible and also that's why
we need democracy we need Freedom so in
a Soviet system for instance you had the
rise of this authoritarian bureaucracy
that dominated of course others in the
name of socialism
now
that system desperately could have used
some political democracy and some checks
on what people were doing and some
ability to reverse the power right and
as soon as of course little elements of
democracy was brought to that system
um the system you know collapsed uh
because there started to be outlets for
for Dissent and for dissatisfaction so I
think we can't design our priority a
perfect system we need to be committed
to certain principles that allow systems
to be perfected and for me that's the
importance of democracy so even a few
years ago not to go on a tangent but
um people were allowing Chinese
authoritarianism and they're saying
China is building this efficient system
the state runs so well there's
technocratic Excellence plus there's
just productivity and they're just
working harder than Americans and and
whatever else but look at in practice
what really happened with covid both the
initial suppressing of information about
what was happening and and Wuhan and the
outbreak were many ordinary Chinese
workers and doctors and others were
trying to get the word out and they were
suppressed
um by by Communist Party officials
locally in in Wuhan properly with the
collusion naturally nationally and now
now with zero covert policies and
whatever else so I think that that often
we find that even though it seems like
these are are weak systems and and
democracy makes us less uh competent
technocratically and otherwise I think
it's kind of a necessity for systems to
grow and evolve to have that freedom in
Civil Society but as for individuals now
the first part of it is yeah I think
people should be free to make their own
choices you might have tremendous
potential but you might choose to spend
it in Leisure and Leisure doesn't only
mean doing you know sitting around at
home drinking a bunch of beers kind of
wasting your life away that way Leisure
might mean spending more time with your
friends and family
building these sort of relationships
that are gonna maybe not change the
world and some some medicines but we'll
change the lives of the people around
you and we'll change your community for
the for the better I'm taking notes here
because I for me at least you've just
been playing a lot of Skyrim this whole
family relationship that I'm gonna have
to work on that I didn't realize that's
also including Leisure because I'm gonna
have to reconsider my whole life here
anyway you know Leisure should mean
Civic activity too right I mean there's
that famous book The the Robert put them
on bowling alone or whatever which
described it for now I mean I'm I'm I
was born in 1989 I like you know um
video and computer games you know
um so I definitely do that type of
leisure too but uh I found a lot more
richness in my life when in the last you
know decade a lot of my leisure has
returned to like going to the local bar
for like the couple drinks I have a week
instead of doing it at home alone
watching TV or something you know
because you get that random conversation
that sense of a place and and belonging
but
I guess what's the undercurrent maybe of
your question was
now if you have a system with lots of
carrots but not the whip of hay you
might be destitute you might be
unemployed you you might not be able to
support yourself unless you're you're
working a certain amount would we still
be as productive would we still be able
to generate enough value for society
um and I think that that's a question
that that is is quite quite interesting
I think that we're living in a society
now with enough abundance that we could
afford
more people deciding to opt out of the
system out of production and that the
carrots of staying in you know more
money for consumption more ability to do
cool things more just social rewards it
comes from being
um successful or from from providing uh
would be enough but that's another thing
that would have to be balanced in a
system so if you're seeing mass
unemployment by choice in a Democratic
Socialist system
then you might need to reconfigure the
incentives you might need to encourage
people to go back into production but
that's something that again you could do
through democracy and through good
governance
um you don't have to set the perfect
blueprint I'm in in motion
um you know write up a Treatise now in
50 years from now you know try to follow
it like it's scripture
so by the way I do like how you said
whip instead of stick in uh carrot and
stick that's putting a weight on the
scale of which is better but yes
um
but I would actually argue to push back
that the wealthier we get as a society
as a world that the more comfortable the
social Nets become
the so the less of a whip or stick they
become
because one of the negative consequences
even if you're on welfare is like well
life is not going to be that great
but
the the wealthier we become
the better the social programs become
the easier life becomes at the bottom
and so you might not have this
motivation financially to get out from
the bottom that said the push back and
the pushback is that there's something
about human nature in general money
aside that strives to for greatness that
uh strives to provide
um a great life a great middle class
life for your family so that's the
motivator to get off from the bottom
well I think a lot of people who are
stuck at the bottom of the labor market
today
um one these are people who are kind of
are are true philanthropists because a
lot of them are the ones who are working
two jobs and are working 60 plus hours
and are providing
um in this country it's such a such a
bargain for their labor because they're
so underpaid so many of the things that
the rest of us use uh to to enjoy life
and consumption or whatever else like I
I got here from downtown
um Austin and I think my lift you know I
did tip but I think my lift was like
eight bucks base or whatever whatever
else you know it's it's it's it's it's
it's the
um I think that we are all indebted to
people who are are working and we don't
see it at various stages of the the
production process from you know the
workers in China and Taiwan producing
um you know technological things that
we're recording this on to
um you know Growers and and and and and
workers and agriculture in the U.S so so
I think that one
um Working Class People are already
working but as far as you know getting
out from under poverty and and
Desperation we're in a society that
doesn't give people a lot of tools so if
you uh don't have access to good Public
Schools uh from you know age five until
you know 12 13. it's gonna be really
hard to move from generations of of your
your family being involved in manual
labor to doing other forms of of Labor
you're going to be stuck at a certain
part of our of our labor market as a as
a result
um if you don't have access to decent
Healthcare you know throughout your life
uh you might be already preordained to
an early grave by the time you that
something kicks in you really want to to
change something in your life and then
the your your mid-20s obviously it's a
combination of agency and all these
other factors there's still something I
think innately human innately striving
that a lot of people have but we don't
really give people in our current
Society the tools to really be full
participants in our society we just take
for granted for example you know from
the Northeast so I give like excessively
Northeast examples we take for granted
that that someone from you know Hartford
Connecticut is going to have
um your average working-class person
Hartford it's going to have a very
different life outcome than someone born
on the same day the same hour have in in
Greenwich Connecticut you know we we
take for granted that accidents of Earth
are going to dictate outcomes so you
mean like depending on the conditions of
where you grew up there's going to be
fundamentally different experience in
terms of Education in terms of the
resources available to you to allow
yourself to flourish yes if you do a
poor City in a rich city and Connecticut
is is great it's highly highly
underrated both New Yorkers and people
from Boston kind of have a colonial
feeling about Connecticut where we make
fun of it and we try to carve it up you
know the West belongs to New York the
east of Boston but you know I'm I'm here
for you know Connecticut nationalism I
think it's it's a great place